die situation ist jetzt schon wieder
angespannt was passiert gerade um nicht
herum
ja die situation ist deshalb angespannt
weil die bewohner hier dieser straße ist
einfach mehr als als wie soll ich sagen
anmaßend empfinden dass wir ruhe
berichten wollen was hier passiert ist
wir sind eben auch mit eiern beworfen
worden auch wir sind beschimpft worden
auf übelste art und weise ich möchte die
begriffe ich ja gar nicht wiederholen
wir haben uns jetzt ein stück zurück
gezogen von der eigentlichen tat
örtlichkeit von gestern weil es einfach
zu gefährlich war
momentan ist es wieder etwas ruhiger
aber die sind wirklich extrem aggressiv
auch uns gegenüber aufgetreten und ja
sie sind der meinung dass die polizei
hier gemacht hat ist das allerletzte und
man hat sich hier nicht festzunehmen
ja und deswegen muss auch darüber nicht
berichtet werden und wir würden sie ja
nur schlechtmachen
von einsicht dass das nicht geht was sie
hier abgezogen haben mit 200 personen
die polizei bedroht haben
davon ist nicht wirklich etwas zu merken
frank jetzt aber erstmal zu dem was
gestern passiert ist warum es heute
überhaupt zu jetzt sehen wir gerade in
diesem moment frank was passiert gerade
weil wir jetzt hier wieder beworfen das
ist das problem ja wir werden da wieder
erneut mit eiern beworfen und findet
dass hier besonders lustig man will uns
hier nicht haben das ist ihr stadtteil
hat man uns gesagt und auch die polizei
hat hier nichts verloren wir auch nicht
und deswegen tritt man uns gegenüber
sehr aggressiv auf gestern nahmen was so
dass hier die polizei ihn festnehmen
wollte einen bekannten straftäter der
noch eine haftstrafe offen hat wegen
nötigung
er wurde dann von der polizei gestoppt
rannte in ein haus wollte sich dort
verstecken polizei center hat ihn
festgenommen er hat sich dann massiv zur
wehr gesetzt geschlagen und getreten
daraufhin haben sich vor dem haus in
kürzester zeit 200 menschen
zusammengerottet und versucht diese
festnahme zu verhindern polizei musste
dann massiv kräfte zusammenziehen und
überhaupt diese festnahme durchführen zu
können und das ist kein einzelfall zwei
tage zuvor gab es einen ähnlichen
vorfall dann 30 personen versucht die
festnahme eines ebenfalls 18 jährigen
wegen gefährlicher körperverletzung zu
verhindern es herrsche eine extrem
die aggressive stimmung gegen alles und
jeden der nach ihrer meinung hier nicht
hingehört und das zeigen die leute eben
auch direkt miteinander zu tun
das kann man so konkret nicht sagen das
ist halt hier ein gebiet wo viele clans
sich bewegen großfamilien und wer jetzt
hier mit wem einzelnen verwandt ist
jedenfalls herrscht gegen die polizei
eine stimmung die hat hier nichts
verloren sie soll hier nicht hinkommt
man versucht hat hier immer wieder zu
provozieren die polizei uns das ist hier
mehr oder weniger der alltag man lungert
hier auf der straße herum und sobald ihr
menschen auftauchen die nach der meinung
der menschen hier nichts verloren
tritt man aggressiv auf so vor den
großen gruppen mobilisiert eben bei
handys und kürzester zeit immer bis zu
100 personen wie gesagt gestern waren in
der spitze sogar 200 und die polizei
brauchte knapp 40 beamten überhaupt die
festnahme durchzuführen und wir konnten
auch mit dem polizeisprecher reden er
hat für uns den vorfall nochmal
zusammengefasst von gestern
streifenpolizisten haben einen 18
jährigen straftäter entdeckt der mit
einem haftbefehl gesucht wurde
der mann flüchtete sich dann in einem
mehrfamilienhaus und konnte dort nachdem
er gegen polizisten geschlagen und
getreten hat festgenommen werden
eine menschenmenge sammelte sich in der
zeit vor dem haus und dem flur zusammen
und teilweise wurden die kollegen
bespuckt und auch beleidigt so also der
polizeisprecher zu dem vorfall gestern
aber zu dieser geschichte gibt es zwei
versionen denn ein freund des
festgenommenen hat mit bild gesprochen
und uns mal erklärt wie genau sieht es
jetzt gesehen haben gestern also die
puzzle kamen hier und meine kollegen
sind der tür eingerannt und die polizei
den täter gewandt haben
festgenommen haben den kaputt gehauen
wir haben den gepackt ja und technik
dünner junger sowieso und da waren
polizei die sind doppelt so breit und
groß geworden kann gelang gegriffen und
so nur weil darauf hatte fehlt sind die
buden machen hier immer noch lässt sie
sich von uns hier weil wir hier
ausmachen konnte
wir sind schnell dass die meisten davon
gar richtig cooler musik groß geworden
sind sind aufgewachsen sind
nur weil er per haftbefehl gesucht
worden ist frank schneider ist für uns
noch immer in duisburg-marxloh wenn wir
das jetzt hören den freund des
festgenommenen er sagt die polizei macht
immer nur stress weil die meisten leute
haben da eigentlich nichts mit der
kriminalität zu tun kannst du uns einmal
noch ein bisschen zusammenfassen was wir
in den gegendruck marksuhl tatsächlich
ist haben jetzt gerade schon mitbekommen
du wurdest angriffe von den leuten da
aber wie muss man sich diesen stadtteil
wirklich vorstellen
ja das ist eine der stadtteile der sagen
wir mal von im migrations hintergrund
durch mal bei 90 95 prozent liegt hier
leben sehr viele großfamilien hier leben
libanesen ihr leben auch sehr viele
türken und es gibt eben straßenzüge die
sind komplett fest in der hand von
großfamilien und plant und hier ist es
eben so gewesen ist natürlich nicht so
dass die polizei sich irgendeinen raus
gegriffen hat beide am sonntag und auch
gestern die person die festgenommen
werden sollen gegen beide bestand ein
haftbefehl einmal wegen gefährlicher
körperverletzung wurde ein 44 jähriger
in einem kino so zusammengeschlagen dass
am anfang noch zusammengetreten
sogar als versuchtes tötungsdelikt
bewertet wurde am ende war es eine
gefährliche körperverletzung ist zeigt
die brutalität und der sollte
festgenommen werden 18 jähriger in 18
jährige gestern hatte auch ein
haftbefehl offen sieben monate haft ist
schon bereits verurteilt wegen nötigung
das zeigt eben es handelt sich nicht um
schikanieren der durch die polizisten
sondern ganz klar sie wollen straftäter
die ein haftbefehl haben festnehmen und
von der straße holen und das ist eine
verklärung einfach der wirklichen
reellen bedingungen herrschen die
polizei muss hier immer verstärkung
zusammen ziehen und wenn zwei beamte ihr
eingreifen mit einem streifenwagen
es ist eine regel immer sofort sobald
sie maßnahmen versuchen durchzuziehen
müssen die verstärkung anfordern weil
zwei personen einfach nicht ausreichend
es gab ja immer die langen diskussionen
gibt es no go areas in deutschland und
die polizei sagt natürlich es gibt sie
in dem sinne nicht
fahren überall in das ist auch richtig
so aber eben ist es die frage inwiefern
kann man sich hier frei bewegen auch wir
journalisten oder ähnliches es sind
schon bereiche wo man sich einfach im
dunkeln nicht mehr frei bewegen kann das
muss man einfach so sagen
und wo polizei eben auch mit zwei
personen in der regel nicht mehr
klarkommt sondern immer verstärkung
anfordern muss im schlimmsten fall wie
gestern abend die hundertschaft vielen
dank frank heider aus duisburg-marxloh